-Chloe, you look fantastic.
-Why, thank you.
-Thank you so much
for coming back on the show.
The last time I saw you,
you were also very dressed up
and looking glamorous
and gorgeous.
We were at the Met Gala.
-Oh! I thought you were going
to say at the coffee shop.
I'm always --
-Yeah, no.
-Yes.
-We were at the beautiful --
-The beautiful Met Gala.
-And you were doing
a red-carpet thing for Vogue.
-Yes, yes,
I was doing the live stream.
-Have you always been
into fashion?
-Ever since I was a small child.
-Yeah.
-I was always, like,
the kid who, like,
I hated wearing jackets.
I hated dressing appropriately.
And my parents would be like,
"You're going to get a cold."
And then my quote was,
"Fashion before death."
-Wow!
-I was like a 4-year-old.
-I have a picture of you
on Halloween.
This is you in the middle here.
-Oh, yeah.
-Now, what what costume is this?
-So, I went as a young adult
in kindergarten.
-That was your --
That's what you went as?
-I really -- I saw this outfit
at JCPenney
and I really wanted it,
and my parents
wouldn't get it for me.
And I've been a manipulator
since a small age.
And I was like, "Oh, no,
it's my Halloween costume."
And they were like --
A little lady.
And then trick-or-treating,
they'd be like, "And you are?"
And I'd be like, "A woman."
-Your your costume was a woman.
-A woman.
-"That's right. I'm a woman."
Yeah.
You were saying to me
that you --
With all these fashion things
you're going to --
Because you're going to
fashion shows.
Have you done an ad
with anyone yet?
-Not yet, Jimmy. I haven't.
-Ooh!
-Gucci.
-Ooh! Gucci!
Why not?
-Why not?
-I think you should be
the face of Gucci.
-I should, but I have
to work on my posing.
-What is the problem
with your posing?
-I don't know
what to do with my hands.
Even as we were charading,
I noticed I was, like, standing
in the camera like...
I have -- I do this thing
called claw hand.
-What is claw hand?
-Every photo I take,
it's like...
or like...
-I have -- Oh, yeah,
I have an example here.
-Here they go.
-I have three photos of you.
-Mm-hmm.
-Very fashion--
very different claw hands.
-Yeah. Yes.
-Now, explain --
That one I could see.
That's claw hand.
-Yeah, that has a pocket.
-Which one? This one does?
-This had a pocket,
I could have hid my hand,
and, yet, here we are.
-This is fun.
I like -- This is very fun.
-Yeah, so, that was at the VMAs.
And I clearly don't know
how to hold an object
with the the claw.
It's like a lobster.
-Yeah.
I did a red carpet once,
and this cameraperson was like,
"Jimmy, give me a thumbs-up."
And I go, "I don't really do
thumbs-up, you know?"
"Just give me a thumbs-up."
And I go,
"I don't do thumbs-up."
"Just come on,
Give me a thumbs-up."
I go...
And then I was in the
New York Post the next day,
and it said, "Jimmy Fallon,
give me a weird thumbs-up."
-No!
-It was weird.
It was a little weird.
-It's hard.
-It's not my thing.
-Right.
-My life is hard!
-It's hard!
They think comedy people --
You know, they want you to goof.
They always want me to smile.
-They want the
jokes and the funny.
-Yeah. I don't like to
smile in my --
-You've been joking and
comedying for five years now
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah, isn't that crazy?
-It's your fifth anniversary.
-A kindergartner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So good. You're fantastic.
-Flew by.
-I love you.
-And this week,
you have Pete Davidson.
-Yes.
-You have Ice Spice.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you get nervous when
you meet the host and the guest?
-Yeah, definitely.
I'm weird with famous people.
-You are?
-Yeah. I try and touch them.
I don't know. They're --
Like, I didn't grow up in L.A.
I don't know.
They're like mythical creatures
to me, the famous.
I saw Jared Leto this summer
and I was like,
"Oh, my God, Oh, my God."
And I, like, soft-touched his
shoulder without him knowing.
-So he didn't know
that you were touching him.
-No, I do it --
No, it's, like, a very --
-Like, what if I'm here?
-I'd be like...
And I don't even say hi.
I just have to know
that my hand has touched them.
-That is so bizarre.
But that's your thing.
-It's normal. It's chill
and cool and totally normal.
-It's chill and cool
and totally normal?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I like it. I think it's fun.
I think it's a nice thing to do.
-Yeah.
-Well, every time you come on,
I'm very -- Thank you.
-Yes! Sorry.
-It's kind of the claw-ish.
-Yeah, well -- Yeah, they are --
-It's a little bit --
They're intertwined.
It depends what you get.
If she likes you,
you get the touch.
If she doesn't like you,
you get the claw.
Every time you come on,
you always do something
above and beyond.
Thank you for playing
that game with us.
And I always kind of
put you to the test
and make you do impressions
or something.
I know -- You're like,
"I know, Jimmy.
I have a job
on 'Saturday Night Live.'
"I don't need to audition."
-They're just impressions.
-But I do love your impressions.
-Okay.
-And I was wondering
if you could do a bunch of them
and how many
you could do in 60 seconds.
If I just name the names,
could you just do a little --
Even if it's a snippet.
-A snippet?
-Just a little sound effect,
something of the names of
people that you do.
Is that possible?
-Yeah.
I want to get as many
as humanly possible.
I'm a competitor.
-Alright.
Alright, let's --
Let's go. Alright, ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright.
-Okay.
-60 seconds on the clock.
Ready?
Go! Meryl Streep.
-Oh, well, I have 600 Oscars.
Jimmy, you and I
are kindred spirits.
You know, you asked me on a date
once, and you said "norr."
Y'all, I just freakin'
love Oprah.
[ Laughs ]
Na, na, na, na.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
Yaaaas!
Oh. Okay, pretend I have knives.
Whoa! Jimmy Fallon!
It is crazy that I'm here!
Oh, and I have a bow!
Shia LaBeouf?!
-Yeah.
-Yo, what's up?
What's good, Jimmy Fallon?
It's penis o'clock.
Oh, God, I-I can't see.
I got my contacts on.
-Oh, my God!
-No!
-That is unbelievable.
That is how you do it!
Chloe Fineman, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Catch the season premiere
of "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend.
We'll be right back
with a performance from Raye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!